-Come on, Cameron.
Oh, we love you.
-Jimmy.
-Come on.
-Look at this. I know it's not
100,000 people, but, come on.
This feels like --
It feels like it, right?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I feel the love. Thank you.
My heart is beating very fast.
I don't, like,
walk into crowds of people
and have them applaud for me
very often. I'm like, "What?"
-We were just talking
backstage about your husband,
who's superstar rock star
from Good Charlotte,
Benji Madden.
-Yeah.
-Whoo!
-But he just played --
Yeah -- oww!
He, uh --
[ Laughter ]
Well, he just played --
Was it last weekend?
-Last weekend.
And he did the
When We Were Young Festival.
It's, like, the pop-punk
festival that was in Las Vegas.
-Link is there and Green Day.
-Yeah, Green Day.
And it was like this whole,
like, sea of people.
First off, Good Charlotte hasn't
played out in like five years,
they haven't done a show.
So here they are, like,
up on the stage,
100,000 people just, like,
singing every word
to their song,
jumping all at the same time.
It was, like, so wild.
I was like, "Oh, yeah, right.
You do that, too."
-Yeah, yeah.
"You're a giant rock star."
-Exactly. He's like, you know,
Benj at home
with being the best dad ever
and running
all of his businesses,
and then he just gets up there,
and he's like,
"Yeah, all right, pyro."
Pfft!
-Yeah.
-You know?
-When he's at home, does he do
songs for your daughter or...?
-Yeah, he makes up --
He has, like, honestly,
I'm like,"Why don't we just --
You need to do a --
like, a kids album,"
because he has, like,
the best songs.
They play in my head
all the time
because he sings them to her,
and she knows the words,
and it's the sweetest
thing ever.
It really is.
It's so -- it kills me.
-I don't think I've ever
written a song for my daugh--
-You haven't?
-No, I tried.
Everyone thinks I should.
-He has some bangers.
I'm telling you.
I'm like, "Whoa.
That is, like -- That's catchy.
-Where was he
when "Baby Shark" existed?
I needed his help really bad.
Yeah.
-Catatonic, like, shaking,
like, rocking in the corner.
-I mean, the "Paw Patrol" theme
was big in our house.
Like, all that stuff.
-Oh, yeah.
But basically, "Paw Patrol"
is just like a pop-punk song.
-It really is.
-♪ Paw Patrol, Paw Patrol ♪
♪ Be there on the double ♪
-Yeah. You can --
-That sounds really familiar,
Good Charlotte fans.
-They should have done that.
They need my help.
The next tour,
I can give him a list.
I also saw, by the way,
you went and saw the Eras tour.
-I did, yes.
-Which...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes.
-I heard it was amazing.
-It was amazing.
I mean, you're like,
"Okay, there you go,"
for three hours, okay.
-And -- Yeah.
And she just does it.
And it feels like 20 minutes --
like 20 minutes.
Here's you and the crew here.
-This is my girls.
Okay.
So, Zoe Saldana is, like,
one of my besties,
and she was like -- we were
talking the night before,
and she was like, "Do you --
Should we go see,
like, Taylor Swift?"
and I was like, "Yeah,
I think we should,
but how are we ever
going to get tickets?"
Then, Elsa Collins calls Zoe the
next morning and says,
"Let's go," and we show up,
and Tiffany is there,
who is, like,
the biggest Swiftie ever.
-Tiffany Haddish
is a big Swiftie?
-Yes! She's like, "I love --
I love this girl."
She's like --
she just goes in on every word.
She knows everything.
-Tiffany Haddish.
-Yeah.
-Really?
I didn't think
of her as a giant Swiftie.
-You know what?
It's a good time,
watching a --
watching a show with Tiffany.
-It's probably a good time doing
anything with Tiffany Haddish.
-Anything.
She loves tea, I learned.
Like,
she's a tea connoisseur.
-Really?
-I'm just like,
"Will you please invite me over
for some tea,
and then we can spill the tea?"
-Yes, of course we can
spill the tea, yeah.
I mean, I want to talk to you
about the wine.
I want to talk about Avaline.
But I also want to talk about --
You did this thing
with Goop over the summer
where you had
your own signature --
signature salad.
-Yeah.
-And I know that you can cook.
-I like food.
-Yes, but --
-Food's good.
-How did you get into cooking?
Because since I've known you,
you've always cooked.
-I just cook with my mom.
Every night, I cook dinner
with my mom.
And me and my mom still, like,
cook together on the phone,
like FaceTime on the weekends.
Like, I'll cook -- cook her --
-No way.
-I'm like,
"Let's cook lunch together,"
and we'll, like,
get on the phone
and FaceTime and cook and talk
and hang out
while she's cooking her lunch.
I'm cooking my lunch.
-Would you ever -- is there --
is there a cooking thing
coming out in the future
for Cameron Diaz?
-I don't know.
It could be.
I mean, all my friends say
that I need to,
like, write a book, a cookbook
and call it "Put an Egg On It."
Because every time, I'm like,
"You just -- You know what?
That's really good. It's really
good with an egg on it.
Just put an egg on it.
Put -- put an egg on it."
I'm really -- yeah.
I'm the queen of morning hash.
Like, I'll take everything
out of the refrigerator
and, like, chop it all up
and, like, layer it,
and then I'm, like -- fwt!
Pmf!
-Put an egg on it! Come on!
-Like, "Put an egg on it,
Call it breakfast.
-Put an egg on it!
-You know?
-Can we talk about --
Let's talk about Avaline
for a bit.
This is a -- this is fantastic,
by the way.
This is one of
the fastest-growing wine
brands in the country.
-Yeah.
-Now, when you first started
this, you came on the show.
Thank you very much.
-Yeah. Thank you.
-And you were like, "Yeah, we're
just hoping to get this message
out and kind of disrupt
the wine industry
a little bit and teach people
how to do it the right way.
-Yeah.
-Now you're one of the leaders
in this category.
-Yeah.
We're really excited
about Avaline being able
to provide
exactly what we wanted,
which was total transparency
in winemaking process.
What's in the -- letting people
know what's in the bottle
and what's not in the bottle.
And so we have multiple SKUs
or varietals and blends.
And this is our newest,
the Pinot Noir,
which is on our website,
drinkavaline.com.
And it's so --
it's the most delicious wine.
It's so good for the holidays.
And we also have
a holiday limited edition
of all Italian wines.
Like, there's --
It's Sangiovese,
we have a Pinot Grigio,
a Lambrusco,
which is, like, so delicious.
-Get in there now before --
You got to order
before the holidays.
Yeah, come.
You'll need it for, yeah,
Thanksgiving, yeah.
-It's good for everything.
-Friendsgiving. Yeah, exactly.
-Friendsgiving, exactly.
-Yeah, you need it.
-And great gifts. Great gifts.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Because that's, like,
literally why I started --
one of the reasons
why I started my wine company
is because all I ever do
for gifting is, like,
just give a bottle of wine
because I want people to enjoy.
I know what they want to --
I know they're
going to drink it.
So now I just, you know --
I give my own wine as a gift.
-I love that you get --
you're involved with this,
every little thing,
down to the color of the label,
down to the little details
that you write.
A lot of wines,
you go like,
"Oh, it has a taste of --
it's a fruitiness. It has --"
You describe this as, like --
You go,
"It pairs well with..."
and you go,
"Oh, what does it
pair well with?"
Food or fish
or chicken or steak.
It pairs well
with fading sunlight
and your favorite song.
[ Laughter ]
And I love that.
-It's a lifestyle.
-No, I love that.
It's so creative and fun.
And why not?
-Right?
-Do something different.
I thought that would be fun,
so I thought
maybe we'd cheers it.
Can we get a fading sunlight?
-Oh.
Let's see if we can do this.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
-We're like the --
-It's like a real, like sunset.
Tuscan sunset.
-We're at The Sphere!
We're live from The Sphere!
[ Both laugh ]
We're at The Sphere
in Las Vegas, you guys!
Yeah. And I was thinking, what's
my favorite song right now?
Of course I'm gonna do
Good Charlotte,
but instead
I'm weirdly into
"Something About You,"
by Level 42.
-Oh, okay.
-You remember that jam?
♪♪
-Oh, cheers, pal!
Ooh, by the way, yummy!
-Yes!
-Whoa! That's fantastic.
Cameron Diaz, everybody.
Avaline is available now
at drinkavaline.com.